here's what would happen if Russia
crashed the International Space Station
Russia has already tested an
anti-satellite missile on one of its own
satellites something that threatened the
safety of all ISS crew members who's to
say they wouldn't take it a step further
orbiting above Earth at 400 kilometers
the largest spacecraft ever built the
ISS is 109 meters passing over India
China the U.S and Europe an ISS crash
would put you at high impact risk in
many parts of the globe as it fell
titanium Kevlar and high-grade steel
would hit the skies in fiery light
explosions
it would look like a comet with a
colorful gas Trail anyone close to the
crash area would be killed or severely
burned in the ensuing explosive Fireball
the impact itself could trigger a
magnitude 6 earthquake so